I went to Davos an interview angelina
jolie and how everyone wanted to just
shoot me because oh my goodness i was
demeaning the coin I wanted to say you
know what last year on the old Nightline
George Stephanopoulos did Angelina Jolie
for a whole half-hour in Washington and
no one said it was the end of Western
civilization you know it was a sort of
different standard and I think a little
bit of it has to do with a little bit of
sexism I mean I think sometimes
sometimes when I do something you know
when the men do it it's very sensitive
and aren't they are they aren't they in
touch with with some sort of zeitgeist
and when a woman does it sometimes
there's a little bit of well you know
too soft
you